the romance languages of I think French
is up there as like number one number
one in terms of I don't know this is
ranking them
oh you guys speak Italian or no not
Italian but we studied French and
Spanish in school and Romanian I feel
like every country calls it a language
of Romance like no but it's Romanian
French Spanish Portuguese
um and I think there was one more that
was like this dialect but those are
considered the romance languages okay so
where would you put Italian I think we
got yelled at so much
okay so it wasn't working it's on the
bottom of the list because people did
not use it nicely but I always really
liked how French sounds
um I I think something about it where
maybe Spanish actually sounds nicer to
the ears but French has more character
and it feels more sultry so I like
French that was my answer too oh sultry
okay yeah I feel like a friendship well
in France I feel like I'm almost being
judged
like they're better than me that's what
Freddy are better
this is so true uh which is why you know
yeah I long to belong to that I like the
British accent the British really yeah
actually one thing we did on our Italian
trip is we just picked up British
accents for the entire trip for fun and
we forgot we were doing them to the
point where we talked to British people
and they'd ask us why are you talking
like that please couldn't stop I I did
feel feel much more elegant and mature
true people like you know I don't know
if they felt the same way about us but
it was more of you know the confidence
you do feel like you're more poised for
sure yeah